but but why are you leaving me I'm a
free agent now yes one way or another
your stash brother Stephen will look
after you now you'll be in good hands
dual bars she'll be right well I must be
going now
it's time for me to test the markets
[Music]
farewell Kevin now I do what I want I
know you and Russ had joys but I can
assure you there will be no such
chemistry problems here well that's nice
to hear
plus you'll have the services of the
premiere point guard in the realm wait
so better than Steph Curry well
certainly top three
well there's Russell and Chris Paul top
three point guard in the East is what I
meant okay
more than this Kyrie Irving's or Kairos
gotta be number one and then Kyle Lowry
he's pretty good these days and a st.
Thomas shortest lady do you want him to
play here or not well I'm just being
honest though you would honesty I'd be
top three easy my max contract shooting
guard wasn't always injured oh so sorry
John I put my body on the line for this
team as I was saying the chemistry here
definitely top five in the in East
[Music]
so what's that what's that over there
what's that box
[Music]
I'm sorry sits soul box sure Bob
so bucks so like a box for souls when
you sign with the Spurs your soul and
your personality are put into the box
right so do I get it back indubitably
haha
so what are your thoughts on tinkin oh
[Music]
it's true if you were to join us you'd
be endlessly ridiculed your old
teammates will despise you and the fans
in Oklahoma will cook this stew on the
flames of your burning Jersey people
will call you a traitor a coward and
some may say you've destroyed the entire
balance of the realm but on the other
hand if you were to join us we would be
[Music]
[Applause]
but we will win not just one
championship not to LeBron I'm sorry you
might want to read this and this wait
not three it's concerned some changes
next year if this is about Delhi going
to the box I think we'll live notes for
what what one is fine some people never
get championships and and we should be
happy with this one
[Music]